joining us on the line is megan and
kelly megan great to talk to you
hey great to be with you ben so why
don't we start by you telling us what is
the new enterprise because
you and i have been chatting about this
offline for what a year at this point
but what exactly is the new enterprise
and what are you looking to do
well i'm kind of sick of regular media
like most americans and
i'm just i'm sick of the fealty that
everyone has to a different corporate
master
whether it's a company that runs the
media organization or whether it's a
politician
who you know like trump or whomever who
they don't think they can they can
criticize in any way shape or form
um and yet i didn't want to go back into
traditional media and have to work for
one of those organizations
and just have an independent voice i
wanted the whole thing to be independent
for me you know so that i could just do
what i wanted to do
and say what i wanted to say and have
the conversations i wanted to have
without you know and if
somebody doesn't like it well uh right
like go watch something else
no problem um i mean i'll take hate
watching too that's okay
but i i don't i don't want to be in a
position where i have to
curtail my language all the time and i
don't think most americans want to be
like that so
hopefully i can be part of this movement
that i already see and already listen to
and you're
at the forefront of it i'm just sort of
doing it the way we want to do it
and sort of helping civilians people who
are non-media people
find ways of expressing themselves
without having to sort of
you know kowtow to these new corporate
standards that don't let you say
anything at any time to anybody
let's talk about that sort of just more
broadly you know obviously you've worked
for a lot of these big media
corporations and
what you do you know in that in those
scenarios is very different than what
you're allowed to do when you run it
yourself
what kind of standards do you see in
corporate media that you think
are sort of preventing the american
people from getting the information they
need
well i mean it depends on where you work
you know i mean it was um it can be
understood
what you're supposed to do or what
you're not supposed to do you know i
mean i would say
it was stressful my last year at fox if
you know you weren't sort of getting on
board with defending trump with
everything he did
um that was a different time and you
know things have changed there since
then i'm not saying it's like that now
but i definitely at times felt pressure
to
you know have an editorial that looked a
certain way and
but but more than that i it's actually
fox was the least
of the problems honestly like having
worked at abc and and nbc and fox
i would say you have the greatest
editorial freedom at fox of any place
i've been
um it's it was much worse at the other
place
and and separate and apart from them
though ben
it's um it's it's basically just the use
of language
so i never put let anybody put an
editorial bent in my story
but it's what you can't say it's like
that line needs to come out i remember
having one argument with somebody saying
what about fair imbalance this is not at
fox i said what about fair imbalance
then the response was well
how about just fair and accurate and so
it's in the eye of the beholder right
like what's
what's accurate i mean i like balance i
i would appreciate to hear the counter
argument but not everybody will offer it
okay so obviously you're you're watching
the uh the 2020 election as it unfolds
uh and you were intimately involved in
everything involved in in 2016 we're
about to approach the debate
let's say that you were given the
opportunity to be debate moderator again
which
uh i have a feeling president trump
would not be fond of but let's say that
that were to happen again
and uh and you had the opportunity to
ask questions to both trump and to biden
what would those questions look like
because i mean frankly i thought that
you did
a good enough job during those debates
that's probably why trump avoided one
where you were specifically
slated to be a moderator yeah i actually
think trump would take me
if i you know if my hat were in the ring
i think he'd say fine because
he knows i'm tough but i'd be tough on
biden too
and uh you know i've already thrown my
fastest basketball at trump and he
handled it just fine
so like how how much more contentious
could it be um
but i'll tell you speaking of that i
would i would have i had to think about
trump
i'd probably ask him something about
the incongruity between the way he
governs and the way he tweets
you know like he totally i know you've
made this point but i agree with you
wholeheartedly he undermines
he undermines everything with his tweets
and i know it's personally cathartic to
him or
sometimes it's strategic he's trying to
distract from something in the news
but if he never tweeted at all and we
just had the trump agenda
i feel like he'd be he'd be ro rolling
right into a second term
even with corona uh so i craft a
question around that
but with biden i would 100 ask him about
tara reid
100 i'd ask him about her i mean if i
were clever enough i'd come up i'd come
up with a way to check his cogniz
cognitive abilities you know like make
them do complex math on the spot or
stuff some things that we could really
just see for ourselves like
i don't know i'd have to think about it
but i don't think that
that mine you know has been explored
enough and
i feel like he did that one in interview
with mika brzezinski and she did an okay
job it was fine
um there was a lot left on the floor
though and
he's never been pressed about it again
you know the media is not interested
and trust me i'd be just the girl to do
it so let's talk about the fact that the
media has been so uninterested in asking
questions abide and he's put a lid
on his campaign meaning that he has not
gone out into public for six of the last
nine days he's just told the media
willy-nilly
i'm not leaving right this basement is
my home and i'm never leaving this
basement i'm not speaking
to you and he's doing at like 9 30 a.m
and there are things happening in the
world like there's a supreme court
nomination that's coming up
there are riots in louisville like
things are actually happening in the
world and he has told the media
that he is just basically taking the day
off and they're just eating it i mean
it's
unbelievable to me that the media have
no serious questions to ask his campaign
about why he's doing it
they're going out there and playing
defense from they're saying things like
well he's probably prepping for the bait
or
he probably has other things to do and i
mean i remember when there's a running
counter
for many members of the media on how
many days it had been since trump had
done like a formal press conference even
though he was coming out every four days
and just randomly taking questions on
the tarmac it's pretty incredible to see
the media bias truly exposed in this
election cycle
well i picture biden like in a bean bag
uh with
dark darts or like um i don't know
netflix
and some popcorn and he's like this is
awesome i'm just gonna cruise my way
right into the white house because
i'm getting away with this it's working
and
um i don't have much longer to go right
like i think it's brilliant
and if you're worried about his
cognitive abilities just look at his
brilliant strategy it's actually quite
smart
that the more he talks the worse it's
going to get for him um
he can just let trump be trump and you
know trump always finds a way to
you know wound himself uh
and so we're almost there he's like done
it for six months now it's one more
teeny tiny month you know he got through
a lot of hard times by doing that and
nobody
is going to press him the media
obviously has no interest in pressing
him on anything
um even like his old plagiarism scandal
where's that like
how did that just suddenly not matter
anymore like i i think it's still
relevant
uh anyway i think it's a good strategy
it
could work but i think that's why the
scotus nomination is probably the best
thing that's happened to trump because
he
biden's gonna have to talk about it and
these riots he's gonna have to talk
about it
it seems like he ran against the hardest
possible line i mean he won because the
alternative was bernie sanders
and if he wants to lock down the okay
well he's just going to be like a normal
guy who's going to bring back normalcy
why not just say listen we're not
wrecking the institutions
the best solution to governance you
don't like is to elect me and a bunch of
democrats in the senate to do a bunch of
things that you do like we're not going
to burn down the institutions
we're not going to stand in favor of
riots we're going to tell antifa that
they should go to jail like
it seems to me like if you're going to
campaign as a moderate campaign as a
moderate but he's been able to have it
both ways so far and i wonder if trump
will clock him on that
it's a great point and think about what
a moment it would be
remember them in the movie primary
colors where john travolta played
bill clinton and larry hagman came in as
the candidate who he was against clinton
and uh
you know the fake clinton and uh he came
in and at the last minute he was like
i'm just going to give blood he was sort
of this above it all statesman i don't
know if you've seen him with this so
good
and it turned out to be a total act it
was insane the whole time
um but even if biden could have an act
that looked reasonable and above the
fray
i think it would appeal to those
suburban women who they're arguing over
i think
you know if he could say we're not going
to do it it's this has been an
escalation
of a nuclear judicial war both sides
have blood on their hands in this war
and i'm going to be the one to stop it
the rules are the sitting president
gets to a point gets to nominate the
next justice and the senate
gets to confirm or not confirm and
that's what's going to happen here
and if you don't like that result then
you need to elect democrats and we'll
switch it
it'll take some time but we will switch
it there are some older supreme court
justices so you got to keep
dems in the senate you got to keep them
in the white house um
but now this is where this stops right
here
i i think it'd be a great moment for him
so the other issue that you mentioned as
one that biden's going to have to answer
on
is all the racial conflict in the cities
and one of the things that we've seen
from biden is that he continues to sort
of
egg it on i mean he's not saying he said
violence is bad he said looting is bad
but he refuses to condemn by name either
antifa or blm and he continues to refer
to what's going on as a quote unquote
racial reckoning which is
an extraordinary way of putting what we
have seen right now
which is legitimately riots attacks on
police officers based on fact patterns
that do not justify the ire i mean what
we're watching in louisville right now
where two police officers were shot
last night as we recorded this and the
and
it's all over a brianna taylor case in
which there is no legal way to charge
those officers with the murder of
brianna taylor it just does not exist
they were fired upon
by somebody in the apartment they
returned fire she was in the path of
fire
she ends up dying that's a tragedy that
is not a crime um and the fact that
biden
is unwilling to quell those waters a
little bit
i mean that that's that's pretty radical
stuff from him it seems i
you know they're never going to in the
same way blm has corporate america
hostage it certainly has
the democratic party hostage and the
thing that bothers me about it
ben as a lawyer which i know you are as
well although i went to albany law
school not harvard
um it is it isn't factual
it's not factual it is factual that that
there is racism
inside the united states and we need to
on a case-by-case
basis look hard to see whether we
believe this is one of them
you know i mean i i'll take the the
central park lady and the bird watcher
right i would have been fine with that
situation if she hadn't
mentioned that she was going to tell the
police he was black right that was
a racist thing to do and say and she's
paid a price for it
but you can't you have to look at
situations one by one
and the problem that's happening now
with this you know hate the police
movement is that they refuse to do that
they refused to look at
the jacob lake situation and you know
recognize that
the evidence appears to be that the man
was armed he definitely had a scuffle
with police he got tased he kept
fighting
he had a cop and a headlock i mean i
could go on
it's a problem you know most of us don't
have really negative interactions with
the cops
that turn potentially deadly because if
we ever get pulled over we submit
you know and that's that's what that's
what most men do because most men
are the ones having the interactions
with cops white and black um
brianna taylor is a tragedy it it is
awful and the the
ag down there was right and very
eloquent in speaking about it
but what was the cops supposed to do
when he took a bullet in the femoral
artery
i mean really what was he supposed to do
what would you do you know and even in
the jacob lake situation
the cop fired when jacob lake allegedly
pulled a knife
and people were yelling you know the
cops they heard the cops yelling drop
the knife
and he didn't right so in that situation
if you're allowed to fire the first
bullet bend you're allowed to file
fire two three four five six seven the
only legal test
is whether the officer had a reasonable
fear
of dying or great bodily danger
an injury and once the answer to that
has
has been decided to be yes he can shoot
to kill
the cops they don't shoot to me it may
not be nice
you may not like it but the law affords
these officers a lot of
leeway because it understands they're in
life and death situations where they
have to make split-second discussion or
decisions
and it's really tough to arm-chair
quarterback it
um and and by the way they're doing it
based on something we don't even know is
relevant which is race where is the
proof that race had anything to do with
jacob lake
anything to do with brianna taylor um
and even
to do with george floyd which is a
special case because the brutality was
so awful and
and really indefensible but but where
did where has it been proven that
race was involved i mean this whole
discussion
leads to a real question which is we've
seen all of this unrest and yet it's not
reflected in the polls for trump you
would figure that this would
down to trump's benefit you'd see some
sort of national gain or gain in
wisconsin whether riots in kenosha
or gains in in pennsylvania or gains in
michigan and you're not seeing
significant gains for trump on this
issue which raises a couple of
possibilities to me one is that it's all
baked into the cake
the election's basically over one way or
the other people have their their
opinions of trump
and that ain't changing and that's just
a question of turnout uh and that's
possibility number one which
seems plausible the other possibility is
that there are a lot of people in this
country particularly
suburban white women who hate
discussions about race they
they they think that the goal here is to
get beyond race and to actually
you know live our lives beyond race and
they've been offered two possible
pathways to do this one is the sort of
conservative response which is
okay we'll take each individual case
individually we'll analyze it and we
will and we'll fight against it when we
see it and then there's the sort of
left-wing view which is
you can alleviate all problems simply by
declaring that the system itself is
racist
that you yourself have been a a
repository of white privilege
and by doing this even just by saying
these words by repeating these words you
are now a member of the anti-racist
codery
and you can expect that everyone will
treat you with a level of respect and
you get to feel superior to all these
other people
who have not done this and i wonder if
that second pitch is actually the pitch
that is winning at this point
i don't think so i i really don't i just
think the loud people are saying that
and people are too afraid to say what
they really think which is
what that what right i mean i was
looking up critical race theory the
other day because
i understood they were doing all these
sort of forced anti-bias classes but i
didn't totally understand what that
meant
and you know one of the things they ask
you to do in these critical race theory
classes
right that you're supposed to go to is
to just be quiet
and sit with your racism
who who is it who wants to do that what
suburban woman is well i mean here on
the upper west side a lot of them
but like no normal person is like yes i
would sit
alone with my come on i mean most people
are fair and they object to the
re-racialization of the country
that's being forced on us right now
right it's like they
there is a school here in new york in
which they are pushing
to offer free tutoring to only the black
students and not the white students in
the coming year
i mean what sense does that make how
what about the black student who both of
whose parents went to harvard
and the parents work on wall street
versus the white student whose mother
had cancer last year she's a single mom
and they're really struggling and he
might be having academic issues like
that we're seeing that we're seeing that
in our schools we're seeing that in our
corporations
and i actually do think if anything has
an effect on on people of saying
i'll give you my vote on november 3rd
we'll get to it on november 3rd when
it is between me and the polling booth
and it's really none of your damn
business
because people are terrified to say that
they like donald trump right now so
that that is the big question is whether
it's possible that all these polls are
just skewed that there is this big shy
tory vote
a lot of people out there who are who
are willing to vote for trump aren't
going to say publicly that they're
willing to vote for trump aren't picking
up the phones
when the pollsters question them uh or
lie
uh or whether they're a bunch of people
who are first-time voters who are not
showing up in these polls because
usually likely voter models pick people
who have voted before your most the best
gauge of a likely voter is a person who
has already voted
it's possible that maybe there are a lot
of people out there in rural america
who are first-time voters planning on
voting for trump in the same way that
there are a lot of people who are not
taken into account in state polls in
2012 for obama it was a lot of
first-time black voters who are not
taken into account
in some of those state polls how big do
you think that shy tory vote is that the
number of people who
just could vote for trump and just
aren't telling anybody about it i think
it's huge
and i don't have any scientific data to
tell you you know just cite that
based on other than the fact that he won
the last time despite the polls and his
polling deficit is around where it was
right with with hillary
um this time during the last election
cycle but i will tell you this
i'm in a unique position sort of because
i worked at fox news for 13 and a half
years
and people know i i'm not a leftist
right i'm not like a hardcore
right-wing person either but i'm not a
leftist and um
so they know all this about me but i
live in the upper west side and most of
my friends are democrats this is
like i'm in new york city most of the
city is democrat and so people will talk
to me from both sides
right like they'll tell me and my
democrat friends a lot of them
will privately when we're alone express
a lot of these feelings
and i do think you know sort of that
more centrist democrat is gettable by
trump but
they would never say that in police
circles ever
um and i think a lot of republicans who
were turned off by trump and still hate
the tweets and think he's too thin
skinned and all you know
this stupid attacks all that stuff um
they do worry about
defunding the police in places like new
york city where they really did take
away a billion dollars from the cops
and it you can see it and everything
from overflowing garbage on every street
corner
to eat a one-year-old who got shot in a
stroller down in brooklyn
you know i mean you might not say that
to a pollster because whatever you say
today they call you a racist they call
you a bigot they call you whatever
um but i think when it's when it's
election day i do think there's a
stronger than ever shy trump voter so on
a different topic i wanted to ask you
about
you know what it's like to be a powerful
woman in media so there's been a lot of
talk about this from the left left seems
to be incredibly hypocritical
about which particular women in media
they defend obviously
if you are you know a powerful woman on
capitol hill and you're a republican
then i guess you don't count as a woman
if you're a powerful woman
who is not of the hard left in media
then you get treated like
you get treated or like my friend megan
mccain has been treated uh by the media
which is uh
as a sort of outcast it seems female
solidarity immediately goes by the
wayside as does powerful feminism as
soon as the woman you're talking about
doesn't abide by
a particular set of political principles
i mean i remember after that trump
debate when trump was talking about you
know my period and calling me a bimbo
and all this stuff like which wasn't
great but like
you know you would think that if if ever
there were a moment for
like now right to like type in with its
holier-than-thou
comments that would have been one bug
kiss they
said nothing nothing i laugh i mean i
don't trust me
i don't need their defense um but what
what's been done to megan
at the view and in response to those
segments on the view
what was done to sarah palin what isn't
done
for nikki haley from melania trump oh my
god the difference in media coverage
between
michelle obama and melania trump i mean
need you look any further
it's absurd it's awful
i mean melania trump is this elegant
beautiful intelligent five language
speaking
awesome first lady who's caused very
little controversy she's trying to stop
bullying i get the contradiction with
trump
but that's we're talking about melania
trump now um
nothing she hasn't been on any magazine
cover can you imagine not on vogue and
anna wintour's like
you know who uh meanwhile michelle obama
is like the second coming it's like
jesus christ came back down and
here she is um so anyway it's stomach
turning to me but it's just yet another
of the million examples of immediate
bias that's out there and i feel like
not even just conservatives you know
people who are anywhere near the center
or writer's center they're on their own
you know it's like you're gonna have to
forge on without the media
without hollywood without sadly academia
i mean i don't know about you but like
i worry about it now because i
definitely don't want to send my kids to
some far left progressive
college you know and they're little now
they're eleven nine and seven
but like at some point we're gonna have
to make a decision on that and i don't
even know what's
available that like what's left the
university of chicago used to seem like
they were sort of resisting the no safe
spaces thing or
the safe spaces thing and then this year
they just said like the only people we
want applying for professorships in the
english department or people who it
promised they're gonna focus only on
black studies
or like well i mean maybe it could be
one
i don't anyway yeah so i don't know
where there is i mean other than liberty
which is like
got its own problems this year i don't
know where you go yeah hillsdale is
going to be overwhelmed with
applications
my feeling on that is that honestly this
is the fault of conservative employers
who have
decided that they're going to use the
same metrics for employment as all
others
other employers which is they're going
to use the sorting mechanism of colleges
in order to pick people because that's
all colleges really are if you've got a
polyside degree from ucla
then all that means that you scored
about 1400 on the sats it does not mean
you're qualified for an actual human job
the way you become qualified for an
actual human job is to basically perform
the actual human job
and so here at daley wire you know my
business partner jeremy he didn't
graduate from college
uh the the president of the company
caleb robinson he didn't i believe
graduated from college so two of the
three leaders of the company didn't
graduate from college so we have a rule
we don't require college colleges on
your application and we will not grant
you extra points in the application
process for having gone to college
until until conservatives start to
actually treat people
as individuals as opposed to you know
graduates of particular schools is going
to be
a serious problem but you know i
i think that's coming i think that's
coming i don't i don't know i mean i
will say
you look at fox news in the lineup there
i mean i can speak to when i was there
right it was like
brett he didn't go to some fancy college
i don't remember where he went
um then i'm just trying to go through
the lineup
o'reilly likes to say he went to harvard
but he didn't really go to harvard he
went to marist i think and like he kind
of counts that one year at the harvard
kennedy school which everyone knows
doesn't really count
um he didn't really go to harvard like
ben shapiro did um
hannity didn't go to college and i went
to syracuse
where there was no iv on the walls but
it was a great time i'll tell you that
a lot of fun times anyway i think
there's a reason roger ailes cast the
lineup like that because
fox then and now has an ability to
understand who can speak
to regular people you know he didn't
want roger didn't want a bunch of you
know first in their class yalies who
were gonna be like
oh my god look at all these dumb asses
at home you know he's like
he knew that would be alienating he
didn't he didn't want it and let me tell
you it was a very different situation
when i went over to
the place that came next so megan where
can people find
your new material where can they find
your new podcast and how can they access
it and help you out
okay so it's gonna be the megan kelly
show and it's gonna be wherever podcasts
are available apple you know spotify
iheart all of them
it's gonna be free so you don't have to
pay anything um
free of corporate overlords and free to
you
and um it's gonna you know it launches
the week of the 28th and
you're one of our very first guests well
it should be fantastic megan kelly
congratulations on the launch of the
podcast
i'm encouraging you to do it for
literally years at this point so i'm
really excited to see how it does i
think it's going to explode megan really
appreciate the time great to talk to you
i'm in your debt ben thank you so much
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content